[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
maybe
[Music]
what's going on guys i'll be starting
probably a little sooner
i gotta set some stuff up real quick but
get just pay with me
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
you guys should be able to hear me now i
believe you can hear me
i need some some confirms in that chat
if you can hear me
why am i still hearing all right all
right all right
addict's world man it's not called
addict's world it's called
the attic show get it right nova
what's going on you guys look look first
off here's the headset
that some of you talking about the
headset is definitely on
my head so what what's going on you guys
obviously we're going to talk about
playstation man we definitely going to
talk about playstation
i don't even have notes this is so
off the the it's so off the wall man i
don't even have notes
stuff has been uh but the looks very
distorted what do you mean it looks
distorted
hold up let me let me shrink it all
right let me shrink it
i don't have any kind of overlays for
the show yet
so you know right now you guys have to
bear with me you got to bear with me
i am going to have some some stuff made
you just got the bear with me man
look right now i don't have any notes
let's
let's let's make that apparent i do not
have any notes
but what i want to talk about is just
what's going on with playstation look
a lot of people in this community you
were talking on the xbox headset
no i'm talking on the the yeti i'm
listening on the headset
i i don't even know why i have this on i
actually don't even need this on
because i'm going to keep it on though
but
addict you notice the sean layton video
getting passed around get jim ryan
out of there look man i don't know what
look
what's okay okay let's let's pull it
back let's pull it back i don't want to
go off topic too too too much what we
would definitely talk
about jim ryan jim dan smith ryan's
that um that you know
king likes to call him at the end of the
day first let's talk about
the direction that their first party is
going
what is the number one thing that people
always gave
sony when it come to the direction of
their games they gave them the fact that
look
they let you be very open they let you
determine how you want to make games
they give you a lot of freedom and
you know one of the things that sony
always got microsoft always got made fun
of is the fact that
look when it comes to microsoft they
give you only
halo only gears and only forza when i've
read that statement
from jim not jim ryan from jason
schreier on how they're only focusing on
blockbuster titles
what does that sound like to you guys it
sounds like you're only going to get
last of us you're only going to get god
of war
and you're only going to get what a
horizon
it doesn't look like they're going to be
very open
with taking risks that doesn't really
benefit them any
is that is that a bad thing no it's not
i feel like
sony definitely needs to focus on the
games that brings them the most money
but at the same time one of the things
that's made
sony where it is now is the ability
to have a very diverse library because
of all the what's what i'm looking for
all of
the man all the the the risk that they
do take
you don't see stuff like gravity crush
on on
xbox because you know microsoft
didn't want to take that type of risk
with xbox
now you know well let's talk about
jim lyon ryan okay he has
come out multiple times with
contradicting statements
saying that you know he he doesn't
believe in backwards compatibility
and then what happens uh he believes his
generation
and then what happens look i'm not
saying that
jim needs to go i'm not saying that i
feel like people
let's see some of the the fruits of his
labor before we really go
too much into what's going on but i will
say that there's something going on over
there
they've shut down multiple studios like
i do think there's something going on
over there like i understand
people are upset
rightfully so because to me
they are a rock skip away from their own
2013
maybe not necessarily the same way that
xbox had 2013 but they're close to it
let's be real here you guys every week
it's been negative news
and there's still there's still no
concern
one second
i honestly feel like sony
me i feel like they're getting cocky i i
feel like
they feel to the point where they had
such a good generation
that they could do whatever they want no
one's gonna call them out on it
thank god for people like jabari and
people like jack move
you know the hardcore playstation people
and people like the iron lords podcast
we'll keep it real with them
we'll tell them exactly what we don't
like about it
but but to me things need to change
microsoft is having a really
good time because sony's having a really
bad time
now i just want to know
what obviously let's talk about a little
bit about the shift of company
all last generation it was mainly
i know you saw the reactions today
people are fed up people are fed up and
they have a rightfully so to be fed up
all i'm asking is let's get past
whatever their equivalent e3 is
let's see what he's talking about
blockbuster we might
you guys might like the blockbusters you
know
instead of funding for 15
indie games and maybe three blockbuster
games maybe they're just gonna start
funding nothing but blockbuster games
you'll get less games but you'll get
better quality games though my
my question to you the my question to
you
is do you want more blockbusters
let's say you were going to get three
blockbusters in the next couple years
maybe you'll get three blockbusters and
maybe
four to five you know double a games
that sony has
typically rehearsed and typically done
my question to you is would you rather
than three blockbusters turn into four
blockbusters
and those four triple a turn into zero
or would you rather
be the same way it's still going now
that's my question
to you i will give the chat a couple
minutes to tell me what you think
to me the three blockbusters is fine
because they're blockbusters sony has
always delivered
in terms of what is going on with their
aaa quality games we've always got
extremely high quality games but to me
it's got to be a mix it can be one or
the other
let me read some of these super chats
shout out to gaming forte with the two
dollar super chat
i like the headset bro hit that like
button like the headset's nice man i
i'll admit it like i was originally
scared that it would be
too it would be to um what's what i'm
looking for
it would be too small but it does look
like it fits on my head pretty decently
now i do wear always like wear toboggan
you guys could tell because my hair all
messed up
like the beard always good but i i'm
getting old man i'm losing hair
i'm becoming like that white genetics in
me man it's taking over man i'm losing
my hair
it is what it is sooner or later i'll
i'll i will be
bald but right now i got the beard
to accommodate and hopefully in the
future i'll have the beard to
accommodate
we got the fight all this chip chat from
lucas augustus you know i can't
pronounce
anything so we're gonna move past the
fact that i definitely butchered your
name
crazy that ps5 has no secondary drive
solution and it's april
good to see you stream lord addict i
don't really care about the the the
secondary drive thing i don't really
play a whole lot in the playstation i'm
playing
spider-man on there but you know i don't
download a bunch of games on
xbox so when it comes to playstation
that's definitely not going to be an
issue because i don't really
go into matters such as like that
all right now let's let's go back to the
blockbusters now
what i want you guys though it's like i
said if you're not taking risks
how do you innovate stuff if you're not
taking risks
how do you cultivate a studio and making
a triple a banger
that they have how do you get a new
naughty dog
oh man did the dmx really pass
uh say it ain't so man
yeah it's looking like he did pass man
uh rest of peace dmx man i i know i know
a lot of you guys think since i'm white
i don't have the right to listen to rap
music but i really enjoy dmx's music sh
you know rest of peace dmx you were a
fantastic rapper
and you really influenced a lot of my
childhood i listened to a lot of
dmx's songs but you know give him a
couple seconds a moment of silence and
then we'll move on with his ramp
all right so like i said rest a piece
dmx
but anyway back on to the sony ramp
listen i understand people are upset
i'm one of you i feel like we need to
speak up we need to be vocal
things like 2013 could easily happen i
don't care
it's like me and my me and laura cognito
has been saying from the start
it does not matter what a system does
it does not matter how good a system
is and for god's sake it does not matter
the track record
i think we can all agree now the track
record's different it's not the same
track record
these are not the same people that have
been selling the playstation ship
it's completely different people and i
think people need to understand
that at any point a company could shift
its priorities
and right now it seems like playstation
is entirely
ran on whether or not how much money
they can make is that a bad thing
that's debatable i don't know if that's
something that you guys
would want in exchange for more
blockbuster games
you don't get more little games all i
feel like is there's got to be a middle
ground and i have personally felt like
sony
has been fantastic with the middle
ground
for years they've been fantastic with it
i just feel like we need to be
very vocal but what i want you guys to
say is
don't be what's what i'm looking for
you can be respectful but not attacking
people
okay go to to the people
up there in playstation tag playstation
tag
everyone you can think of that has
relevancy in playstation
and just say i'm not agreeing with the
way you're going
you don't have to call people names and
stuff to get your point across
and to be perfectly honest with you if
you are
going that direction and you're saying
stuff like that
playstation is not going to listen to
you anyway
yeah people might not have liked gravity
crush
but there are a lot of people that did
one of the things that's made
playstation what it is is the fact that
they could be
so diverse that has always been a
beneficial to playstation
and the fact that you know right now
it's looking like
we're re playstation's not gonna have
that diverse library
and another question i have for you guys
is do you think because playstation
isn't going to invest into certain
brands
or certain titles do you think we're
going to get a gears
halo and four is the kind of thing do
you think kid smooth
is about to start making a game a
a song about three to four games that
playstation has
well what would it be god of war i think
jason schreier said something about the
making another and chartered um
you know uh the last of us horizon zero
dawn
is these only blockbusters we're getting
are they never gonna do anything else
besides these games
i'm just i'm just curious man uh them
losing mlb
what's going on with that what is going
on with that
we need answers because it just
it feels like the answers aren't where
it needs to be
i just we could talk about that let's
talk about that
how are you going to remaster something
that was already remastered
you could have took the money that was
invested in that and make days gone too
sure i didn't like days con 2. i mean
days gone one
i didn't play a whole lot of it now i
have it on the playstation
i'm going to reinvest time to do i don't
know if i'm going to do that now anyway
because they're not making a sequel
you could have invested the money it
took to remaster
last of us to last to today's gone too
yeah they're already using god of war
and horizons a lot
sony has third-party games they have
third-party games
and i get that they have the personas
but let's be real
microsoft has been stealing those
third-party games they've got the
yakuzas
they've got the dragon quest we have to
see it that continues
which the white phil spencer has been
going i think
it is going to continue so they continue
to lose third-party support
that's exclusives where are we
we are with the last of us we are with
the god of wars
and we are at the horizons and the
uncharteds because
the clearly it seems like they're not
going to be investing
into new ips we have always i mean not
new ip's uh new uh
sequels i've always been a vocal person
her uh rice and rum should have got
an uh an update it should got a sequel i
feel like recourse she got a sequel
sunset overdrive should have got a
sequel there it looks like they
pitched a uh um
oh man what's that game called i already
forgot
that damn game oh my god man i'm
i day's gone too day's going to i don't
know how i messed that up
now look if we don't get days gone twos
where are we can someone explain that to
me
if we don't get this diverse library
that sony has
always gave us what is different about
the playstation and the xbox
i got to know that good point other zinc
where is killzone
where is days gone too i mean astrobots
doesn't look like a blockbuster game
are they gonna stop reproducing that
game too
shout out to k-pop uh to cop
901 i definitely apologize for
announcing your game
uh your your your name is k-pop it is
not k-pop
guys know i can't pronounce something
sony studios don't
uh really does not have diversity they
used to have diversity
not necessarily huge diversity but they
did
but it seems like now they're not
prioritizing that it seems like now
their number one focus is on what
blockbuster titles
guess what cost a lot of money to make
blockbuster titles
guess you could if if you may if you
only focus on blockbuster titles
you cannot have a huge point in games
you can only have probably half of what
sony was having
let me see my voice is going out you
guys that my voice is going out
someone said it's not bad and we're just
i've been okay now
the studio that made kills on created
horizon what's your point
my point is is the game needs to be made
there's plenty of fans for the franchise
like so i mean we're just not gonna make
it because it's not a triple a banger
it's something you like
yeah i don't personally like um horizon
zero dawn would you just stop making
that game i don't i don't like uncharted
we're going to start making uncharteds
you can't have that i want it's
only important to me i might do the
attic world thing but it's a joke
i i could come to realization that
certain things that people make is not
for me
it's see if these definitely isn't for
me but
clearly everyone else likes that game
i'm clearly the minority on that
get sony got no rpg xbox snatch it up
it's a good question about rpgs sony's
clearly not trying to pursue that
whatsoever
what happens if microsoft does buy sega
and they lose persona
is that going to be cause for concern
because i i think you guys aren't
looking at the bigger picture here
some of you are and i'll i'll give you
guys that god of war and spider-man have
lit been milk within the last three
years
um they now start a war for png
a moving png still don't think that's
coming out
it is it is simply
amazing how things are going but you
know i want to know how you guys feel do
you feel like
the the the middle ground was better
that they were doing where
sony would focus more on double a and
then have your
aaa bangers and the the difference is
with sony when they made a triple a game
besides days gone it was a day it was
damn triple a game
you got the god of wars the ghost
fushimas the horizon zero dawns
they were triple a games my concern is
that sony's only gonna let
naughty dog insomniac
gorilla games then make it and that's
all
five dollars super chat to fonzie why is
no one talking about the scorpio issue
hindering software
sales what do you mean by that you mean
that people are buying
the the sculptors are buying the the
playstations and the xboxes
to a point with uh that no one can get
them so no one buys the games
because a lot of these games have been
cross plats so
unless you sold your playstation you
would still have access to them
room here's 90 dogs remastered and last
of us one again
i don't think it's naughty dog i think
it's ben's studio
being assisted by naughty dog that's the
way jason schreiber made it seem
jack and dexter i remember jack of
dexter it was a great game
where are they who owns jack and dexter
hold up
let's see let's see who owns jack and
dexter
jack and dexter
trademark i put track mark
all right let's see here
curious who owns
jack and dexter
let's go to wiki see who
it looks like they've published the
majority of them i i guess sony
owns it sony has to own it five dollar
ship driving ray uh
raiden blade playstation is the only
real income for the company all the
profit has to
filter back into the corporation as a
whole totally agree with you here's
another question i have for you guys
do you think that there's a chance that
this isn't because they want to focus on
the
aaa titles uh and not focus on double a
or do you think this is a monies thing
where they can't afford to do both
anymore
so they have to do one or the other king
like sometimes i think his his takes are
out of this world
crazy but he has always been
on that position where sony is on
the verge of of going bankrupt
maybe so okay what's going on
hold up let me quit all this stuff that
my computer's doing
it doesn't need to do all this i don't
know why it's doing all this
get out of that i don't need that we
don't need steam
i don't need that i don't need the xbox
thing
all right so things should things should
start to clear off here in a couple
seconds
what are we talking about we talking
about the state
of playstation
and where they are and where they should
be and where we could go
all right so we got a two dollar troop
trap for robert slade jack and dexter
and sly keeper back asap
i i hate to be the bearer of bad news
but if they are not going
to invest in the stuff that's not
blockbuster
you're probably never going to get those
games back now here's another question
is ratchet and clank going after this
next game if it doesn't sell well
are we in a scenario where if sony
invests into one game
and it doesn't do the greatest is is the
franchise over
because that's the way it's looking it's
looking like
they are trying one time and if it's not
good
out of there get out of there we don't
need that
i'm just i'm i i'm literally baffled
the way sony is acting right now and i
know some of you
addict you're you're an xbox fanboy i
got a playstation 5
right the hell there it i i played
spider-man last night played like an
hour and a half to two hours of it i got
a playstation i have the right
to ask where their company is going i
got an xbox i have the right to ask
where xbox is going
there is nothing no one could tell me
that try to silence my opinion
to make me feel otherwise
sony seems to have lowered their budget
this gen the question
is did they lower it because they want
to focus on just triple a titles
or did they lower it because that is the
only funding that they can do
yeah i looked it up forte they do own it
so they could if
they could definitely make that game if
they want it could easily make that game
and the question is how much could a a
double a game really cost them
they probably spin but there was rumors
going around that they were trying to
pick up
star field last year and that's
that would probably cost them a lot of
money
so my question is are they willing
you mean to tell me they're focusing
more on marketing deals and timed
exclusives
than they are at cultivating and
building their own studios
is that where we are right now because
it feels like that's what's going on
because someone explained to me where we
are because i don't know
what's up big cloud what is um
do you want to address the people big
cloud do you want to talk
to the people because i will jump into
discord
i will jump in once so fast now keep in
mind big cloud
if you decide you come in here and you
roll up and you want to give your
opinions on stuff
we are doing stuff pg on the attic show
now man
that is the compilation of coming on the
iron lords podcast is
we got to keep it family friendly so
don't be cussing man that's all i ask
don't cuss
gotta keep this for the little kids i
don't think i've cussed this park
this stream i might have if i have i
apologize [ __ ]
whoa all right now i'm starting to
starting to starting to get it man
starting to get it
i understand the the concept i know
what's going on man
i know what's going on all right i'm
about to go on discord
so let let's see
let's see what this man's got to say
let's see what he's got to say
go into the attic world and feel free
anyone that is in
our iron lords podcast and have the
accessibility
to go in to this
go into the attics world if you don't
know what the addicts world is
then i guess you're just not invited to
the show
you're outside the club you're just not
in the club i'm in there right now
you can come at any point and talk
what's going on in your mind
i want to hear what big cloud
has got to say it's going to be
interesting man it's going to be
interesting
i can't do this very long i'll give you
guys some like 130 maybe
but i can't go too too much farther past
that because i got a job and stuff
i got i gotta i gotta i gotta make the
money man
i got i gotta live
so one thing i do wanna ask you guys is
when do you think these games are coming
out do you think god of war is coming
out this year
what about horizon oh i gotta drag him
in
what's up big clown what's going on hold
up
hold up you're on the wrong thing
it goes to
oh that's right my i haven't talked to
my headset so long it turned off
look i didn't think i needed it for a
second all right try to talk now
yes now i just gotta change this
all right talk now
why isn't it popping up in here man see
the this is the pc stuff man this is the
pc stuff
oh go to disney there we go there we go
yeah it's working out it's working out
all right cool we are good how how do
you feel about this
let's just let let me set it up for you
man let me set it up so you can hit it
out of the park
yes sir first off how you feel about the
fact that there might not be a day's
gone too
go uh well that right there is the
biggest surprise of all
because that game had a lot of potential
yeah it didn't get a crazy reception
at all from everybody but the thing is a
lot of people fail to realize
that game honestly that game would have
benefited three times over
if it was on ps5 that would have been a
game to showcase ps5
especially when we're talking about ssds
we're talking about bandwidth we're
talking about performance
that would have been the game to
showcase on a next-gen console
and then pushing that to the next you
know level with us
what a sequel should have definitely
been the thing the fact that we're not
getting that
is ridiculous in my it's done
and they're giving this last of us
remake over that
who asked for last was remake attic i
didn't
nobody nobody asked for this you know
what i
preferred i would prefer them to remake
the second one and give me a good story
but that's besides the point
oh bro bro yeah we only want to get into
that bro we need you in the same camp we
don't want to go in that story though
because you know how people are with
that
but here's the thing i was just talking
with boom and all them about this one on
boom show
my thing is this if you're going to
remake the last of us one
what exactly are you going to do are you
going to redo scenes i think you're
going to add unnecessary scenes in here
like for example
notice how they're pushing abby right
are they going to add abby scenes in
last of us
what are you doing here i don't get it
they might i think
they're really just focusing on the
gameplay aspect because i i think that
they know that the the title would sell
regardless
and i think that their concept is if we
re-release the game we're gonna make
money
and i think they're gonna make the game
play more like last of us part two
but then again you you make a good point
maybe they're trying to
uh make the second one have more of an
impact because she's in the first one
i don't know because here's the thing
though remember the big mis the big
mystery in part two
is who is this woman remember so it's
like if you spoil it in the first one
that kind of defeats the purpose of the
second one like a lot that takes a lot
of tension
uh the second one unless you do like you
know i mean unless you're trying to do
the same thing with part two
and the thing about this as well
this goes again it's like this go this
went back to etheric i don't know if you
remember when i said you know i could
see factions going to pc
in the future i'm wondering if they're
doing this for factions
to go today and like day one on pc when
they do this when they launch it
i feel like i feel like that's
definitely a possibility i think yeah
there's a really good chance that you
know would be crazy
if factions they want to charge for
factions but i think they know they'll
get obliterated
oh yeah but at the end at the end of the
day
i feel like they're like yo ben studio
what you doing
oh we're making days going to no you're
not making days gone too you're making a
remake the last of us one
so i can bundle this faction stuff in it
and we could pop that out there as a
bundle and make people pay for it pretty
much all the same customization from the
first one repackaged just in 4k
with the different asset that's it all
the game all the guns by the way mind
you
that broke the online and in the long
run you know they're gonna repackage
those into the game for the remake
the thing is though we've already
experienced it and i'm wondering again
if they're doing this if they're doing
this for that stupid tv show
that's just even more stupid that's even
more dumb than me personally it's like
it's dumb i know that you might not
agree with this next aspect that i'm
about to say
yeah but what happened in 2013 with xbox
they were focusing on tv shows they were
focusing on
just halo gears and forza like i'm not
saying that sony's there because they're
not
why someone does but i am saying that
they are they are a rock throw away
from being in that scenario i mean how
many last of us games have we got in the
past couple years
we got last of us two um last of us
remake
remake one then we had a lot and we had
lassos right now you're gonna get
another one
in a tv show and a tv show that's that's
definitely falling into the halo gears
and forward to
halo gear support you know it's like bro
i'm sick of um listen i love last of us
one
i am not i repeat i do not love last of
us part two
i love the gameplay but i hate the third
act of that game i hate that whole third
act i didn't think that was needed
but which one was the third act it's
been so long
you know like when you get uh so
basically that whole part with
uh the second half of the game near the
end oh so you're talking about
yeah i felt like abby was a good
character they just introduced her
in an incorrect way it should have been
like day one you plays both
abby and ellie and then you go into day
two
i understand the reason they did it they
want it for like
effect wise but like you don't even see
abby see her
friends dead you go straight from you
killing her boyfriend and that chick
or her ex-boyfriend to she capping you
at the library
at the theater eater and i'm sorry if i
just spoiled stuff for you guys but the
game's been out forever
okay so you know what they should have
done though honestly um they should have
just started the game off with you
playing against abby to begin with and
like it
shows during the chaos type of thing if
that makes sense i would have done that
and built up to who this character is
what exactly is happening
who killed all this and then play a mind
trick on everybody
right when you see ellie through her
perspective that probably would have
connected you more welly and then you
see her kill joe
boom it was tripping me out that uh yeah
that when you fought ellie in that
theater i didn't want to do it
yeah i did not want to hurt ellie i'm
like bro i don't want to beat up ellie
and that's because they built abby to be
the bad guy and they made you fight the
good guy with the bad guy but we ain't
getting into that too much
that's not what this is about
playstation doing this
i told people again i told people even
in my livestream
i don't know if you saw it but i told
you i was listening change is coming
people
it's time for you to be open and keep
your eyes open you're going to see a lot
of stuff different with playstation
you're going to see a lot of different
you know like different things they've
never done before in the past you're
going to see this stuff
i had people saying there's no way
there's no way they're gonna do that
oh they're not gonna make money with
game pass they go a game pass moniker
and here's the funny thing about this
whole people saying oh game pass the
whole game pass marker
i see a lot of people saying sony's not
gonna make profit
with a game pass moniker now attic
has sony ever dropped quality in their
first party content
uh you say that again has sony ever
dropped the quality in their first party
content
not really
there's been exceptions with certain
games that hasn't been up there but
for the most part if it's coming from
naughty dog saint monica
or gorilla it's going to be high quality
right when you have these games
you have studios like sony sony is
always going to set the bar
when it comes to the games now if they
had a game pass moniker go let's give it
a buck
have these dudes who cap for a lot of
these playstation games they're not
paying 70 bucks
up front for them they're not these
dudes are not paying for it they're not
this this is so proven with what day has
gone like oh i love days gone
i'm a big fan of dave's gun and they go
oh you know you found him they just got
today's goal you know i mean
they didn't buy days gone when it
mattered
you got the body you know you they
didn't show the support for it they
didn't really show that that game had
potential me
i even said it in my review for days to
go on i said dave's going's got
potential it just had a buggy launch the
the game did not run properly you know i
mean that was it
if they would have fixed the glitches if
the game would have ran smooth
it would have been a much better score
for a lot of people but the thing do you
think that the glitches
because like right now we're in a very
high
sensitive social media aspect like oh
yeah uh for instance now since like
stuff like
tick tock twitter facebook which not
necessarily facebook a whole lot these
days youtube
you make a game that's buggy it's it
it's it's everywhere at that point yeah
you're gonna make die at that point
people are joking about it on tick tock
you're becoming a lie
look what happened with cyberpunk it's
not as bad obviously
but even if that game had minimum issues
it was still everywhere on twitter that
it was everywhere on tick tock and
what's funny is the next gen versions
ran decently fine it was the last gen
versions
so to me it feels like do you think that
day's gone being
busted when it came out because it
wasn't necessarily not playable but it
was a lot
of issues do you think that that came
out and affected itself
oh yeah i i i definitely uh believe that
honestly like all the stuff that we're
seeing
with these games it's just like even
with cyberpunk cyberpunk is a prime
example of
and they any and here's the funny thing
about cyberpunk a lot of people set that
game up film
when we talk about this addict where i
said the you know that game has got
unnecessary pressure on it
you made that conversation i was just
telling people i'm like yo bro
y'all y'all y'all comparing this to the
witcher i'm like that's a good
different thing this is a whole new ip
this is something completely different
you know what another game stuff yeah
you know another game that that got fell
victim to that
what's up um read that too
yes sir like they're like oh you know
look what look gta did it's going to
have this much success no
it's not gta was a phenomenal for
multiple reasons of the majority of it
was online
because they could sell you the back to
the future car
they could sell you all kinds of stuff
you can't have a car like that
in red dead it's never going to be the
same feeling like
the only thing going to dethrone gta 5
is gta 6. yeah what really killed
um like even they they even tried to
throw um
gta online into red dead 2 you remember
that like they tried to do the whole
gold with the shark card thing they
tried their best to incorporate it
it's like that stuff doesn't translate
into that particular setting like what
exactly are you trying to sell people in
the game you know what i'm saying that
they had like the
they had like the basic necessities they
were trying to sell us for gold bars
the most expensive thing in that game
were close
i'm talking a hundred dollars just for
some new clothes like oh
man like they they didn't do that right
they they didn't have that well thought
out and it just it
definitely shows and but cyberpunk again
with this with the way the internet is
as of late there's no room for error
type of thing you know i mean you can't
you can't do it look what's happened to
the outriders like it's got massive
connection issues for the first like
week and now they
i mean it's it's crashed on my xbox
multiple times like
to be honest with you i think i had less
issues with cyberpunk on next-gen car
hardware
like like playing out uh wilds
or outriders that's what it's called out
right
there's just so many games without in it
now outriders our
outer wild uh outer worlds
yeah but outriders like you could get
i want i've always been one of those
people i don't want a game to fail
yeah but at the same time i don't want a
studio
that deliberately put even if it's the
publisher because i know
i i hate that the developer has to take
the hit because most of the time they do
because the most the time it is the
studio it's the publisher it's not the
studio
uh that they rushed it out they didn't
give them the correct support they
needed
i've been told that square enix has a
lot to do with what's going on outriders
right now
and i hate that the developer has to be
clatterall damage
but i've gotten to the point with these
broken games that i don't care at this
point
it's like release a solid game
or get obliterated that's true that is
true
and here's the funny here's the even the
bigger magnifier about this dude i
brought this up
so many times uh oh aaron summers
um actually he just passed away bro he
just passed away dmx he just passed away
uh to today he was on live support
yesterday there was uh
it was false sinful he didn't die
yesterday but he died today
probably what happened is is they were
going to take him off the ventilation
machines today
if someone jumped the gun and said it
was yesterday you know it's like i said
moment of silence for him man he
he was a he was a great influencer in
the industry
he made a lot of that industry what it
is today and uh
my heart that goes to him and his family
absolutely but um
to go back to this i mean it gets
sidetracked um
remember games are now had and they now
have this seventy dollar price tag on it
right
seventy dollars when you have a seventy
dollar price tag on games like this and
you don't have no cheaper option to
experience it
bro you're gonna have people do what
look at it with magnifying glasses
destruction all-stars is a prime example
of this
return absolutely is a prime example of
this
right it's like bro nope like
everybody's looking at like what
what exactly does this game have to
offer like i remember that game quantum
era you remember quantum era the
trailers for it
i was like quantum era it doesn't look
like that's going to be a big
good launch title we see the gameplay of
it i'm not going to lie it looks very
interesting
but that's you know that's on their part
that looks good
but other games you're having problems
especially new ips bro you need to legit
come out swinging and show that you're
worth that price tag
and sony's case microsoft has this
alternative that where if they do go to
70
what do they have addict for fifteen
dollars a month you can buy
you can you can experience it and if you
like it then buy it
if you you know you know what the worst
part about it is
you're you're losing a lot of the the
faith
and the the trust that you're having
with your consumers when you put
something like
um uh the all-star game whatever that
game was construction all-stars
and you're putting out that for 70 bucks
and then it's out there for a month and
he gets dropped to 20.
that dropped instantly so then
the consumers are thinking were you were
you
what was that about like like i'm
assuming people they didn't have
playstation plus that bought that for 70
because they
got to be people that bought it for 70.
like do they get a refund
like am i assumed because return was
coming out for 70 is it going to be 40
next month
right like playstation
it feels like there's miscommunication
and there's not miscommunication if that
makes sense like
i i i feel like playstation i feel i
personally feel like playstation gotten
cocky that's what i feel like
i feel like that uh they've gotten to
the point uh
that they know that people love their
blockbusters and there's nothing wrong
with blockbuster titles we all like
blockbuster titles but you do have to
have some
form of a game that comes out there that
makes your library more diverse
if they need a multiplayer they really
need a game with a good
multiplayer type of following that's why
i really think socom
is coming back but we don't know if it
you know i mean like we don't know when
who's gonna do it how they're gonna do
it but that needs to be a true
uh thing that's happening with sony
we've heard so many things like i
covered the castlevania
reports the metal gear solid reports
right
and um there was another one i think uh
that was coming out for it as well
silent hill
so it's like they need those uh big
um hitters at that point they really do
so someone in the chat
normally i don't really address the chat
but we're gonna address this one
uh he said so it was better to leave the
game at 70 after the backlash they got
people
that pre-ordered got refunds that's cool
they got refunds
that's besides the point the point is
sony
had the audacity to try to sell you that
game at seventy dollars
you can look at that game just a trailer
and see that's not 70 dollars worth the
game
bro they showed a small snippet of that
game
um back when they first showed the ui
and they were showing sack boy on the
ps5
you know what i mean you're in that act
they showed at the end when they took
the screenshot
you could just tell that was not worth
70 dollars
it's just not worth it and a lot of you
guys are going to tell right off the bat
like i'll tell you right now
resident evil village from what i just
saw from the ps4 version i don't know if
you saw that attic but the ps4 gameplay
that ps5
though is going to gamepl worth 70 bucks
that's what i'm trying to get over it's
not and especially
like you know doing it's like i'm not
saying that
they they messed up completely with the
70 all-stars i'm saying that that kind
of mentality
lowering a game price point that goes
from 70 20 which is a significant amount
now you'll have people thinking do i
really want to pay 70 for return
or wait for it to go down in price
drastically because that wasn't
that wasn't a sell that was a price
reduction
you don't see that often i think that's
the only time in gaming history
i've seen a game go from its permanent
price of 70 to 20 in a month
yep but it is what it at the end of the
day
what do you feel needs to be done do you
feel like
do you feel like jim ryan need to go
that's my question to you do you feel
like maybe
he's too much into the money and he's
not thinking about the ecosystem as a
whole
or you think yeah i mean obviously he's
there to make money
just like kaiser i was there to make
money sean layman there was was to make
money
the thing i i am really not liking about
him right now
he's not taking risks you see part of
the thing that makes
sony stand out is sony took risks
you see what i'm saying like games that
you at least expect
sony threw out there we got the the
insane set piece type titles we got the
days gone we got all these
d those type of like actions are the
reason why
the playstation 4 was the system that it
was
you know i'm saying you need that type
of sony to really compete
him just doing what he's doing here he's
just looking at analytics of how the
game did prior he's like you know what
let's just redo it again repackage it
like horizon zero done going to pc we
knew that was going to happen eventually
because you know he's trying to get eyes
on the sequel
but god forbid if he says horizon zero
dawn gets a
ps5 remake
see what i'm saying that right there is
killing me it's like bro
you're remaking stuff that's already
been that's already done
its job and you know what's the build
upon it you know what's crazy
i just thought about this they put days
gone on pc and they knew it wasn't
getting a sequel
yep so
days gone sold well too it wasn't like
it was a flop
sales wise so like i get that it got a
bad reception like review-wise and stuff
but like okay would we have the last
uh would we we wouldn't even have the
last of us that they had that mentality
back then
that we wouldn't have uncharted two
through four
because i'm pretty sure uh whatever they
do with unchartered two
what k when did last of us come out
between three and four
uh yeah yeah so if they wouldn't if they
would have
had this mentality back then last of us
did okay just
didn't do what we expect they're having
xbox mentality at the beginning of the
xbox one generation
they're having it didn't make enough
money for me to reinvest
so we're cutting it and then if they
didn't do that they went back
i mean obviously naughty dog would have
went and did something else
then they wouldn't have made last of us
and last of us
arguably saved the company it did
it did like untry to like uncharted
the game that put them back on the map
with ps3 but it was the
you know it was last of us that really
like was like this
was like the end all like best cherry on
you know top i think i think
that was it i think what happened is the
last of us came out
and it was one of those just
it came out at the end of the generation
and i think that's that's what
really captivated like when you're
buying an xbox one
like what have you played oh i played
halo gears and forza well
not really so much forza back then but
and then you you're looking at it on a
playstation side well what is the ps4
gonna have well last of us just came out
and that was phenomenal
yeah so like there was a lot of
mentality going to that and that they
would have had that
well too much risk i'm not making an
uncharted 2.
arguably the company might have went
under like yeah
oh yeah like again it all is it's always
going to come down to who's willing
to make an effort who's willing to make
those big
risks who's willing to really step up
you know to the play type of thing
you really got to bring that type of
like heat
and i've said it before like
competition's good right i'm expecting
good things from sony
and then they do this announcement it's
like well this doesn't really spill
you know i mean this doesn't spell
excitement it doesn't do anything of
that nature it's like bro this is not it
that's not it you need to go back to
your roots and really bring it back like
you see how many tweets sean lane's
getting right now are you have you seen
twitter
no john wayne's got more tweets to these
guys in a long time everybody's saying
we miss you charlie we missed that
like show on lady got it like regardless
how people might felt
uh feel about sean layton on stage sean
lane understood
and you don't make it happen you know
what makes this even worse
yeah that sony could not have picked a
worse time to start
acting up like they're doing because now
it's no longer the scenario where
they're messing up and xbox isn't doing
anything
xbox is making crazy moves and
playstations messing up
oh yeah so we we got a fight on subject
from dayron colon
that definitely messed that up we're
going to move past that
on brexit boom this morning was
mentioned the last reverse roommate
could uh be due to the fact that the
game is getting a show
it would bring new players last of us
two just came out like
like six months ago six months ago bro
and on top of that we've already the
hardcore
have already experienced last of us one
so you mo
really the hardcore the ones you would
be trying to get to watch the show right
repackaging that game is not going to
put new eyes on the show
at all not even for the older newer
people
out here like that's just not going to
do it i honestly don't see that
and it's it's just it's just a it's a
it's a terrible take it's it's a
terrible it's a terrible thing
and we've seen if if a show is good
it's going to sell itself you're not
going to have to
to to invest millions of dollars into a
remake
if a show is good i'm going to be
telling [ __ ] i'll be like
yo this yeah last of a show lit he gonna
be telling
all his people and before you know it
they we've done their job for them
i mean we just recently did that with
one division people one division was
fire
they sold itself at the end of the day
sony just got to get the act together
and
you know and it's like i was telling cog
a couple weeks ago i was like you know
be crazy at the end of this generation
if jim ryan makes playstation the most
money they've ever made
and what yeah because of the because
like
obviously i do believe he's devaluing
the brand to a point
uh he's devaluing the brand to like pc
people he's devaluing the brand to
certain people but
it's not what people think like to a
consul person which is the primary
target he's not devaluing it uh but
to everyone else he is so we got another
five dollar subject from dave ron colin
look at what happened with the witcher i
think they're trying to do that movie
that move i get that what's your though
what's your three there's very few games
that come out to have that success like
what your three did
which are three is literally a game of
the generation moment
you can have a hundred putt developers
make a game like witcher 3
and maybe one of them will come out with
the type of game that witcher 3 actually
is yup
but you know let's say
let's say but before we end this because
i do got to talk about the headset real
quick
okay when it comes to the playstation
let's say that
we put you in jim ryan's seat we got jim
ryan
out of there he's gone why would you fix
playstation right now
how would i fix playstation oh it's
humble first of all
i would bring back games that people
want for one
like see sony is suffering from what
nintendo's suffering from right
nintendo has so many ips underneath
their umbrella
but they only focus on a select few if
that makes sense like they only put a
few
into the spotlight sony is in the same
boat
there are tons of games they could be
already showcasing
and bringing back like where's jack and
daxter for god's sakes where's sly
five where is um where's the other game
twisted metal where's twisted metal that
was reportedly coming out
where's daxter coming you know where's
that stuff so they have a lot of games
underneath the umbrella
they can easily be highlighting going
hey guys this can get remake
or whatever hell we heard the reports of
uh like again with um
uh konami where sony supposedly is
working to get metal gear remake
why not have that be your big
announcement as opposed to this being
your
your announcement it just doesn't make
sense to me but i would have that i
would be that
i just feel like they need to get back
to the core
i don't mind the direction that jim
ryan's going i don't mind i'm putting
stuff on pc
i don't you know i honestly feel like
the
the mlb thing was out of their control i
feel like they signed a contract
that didn't anticipate something like
game pass i don't think sony expected
them to make moves like they did in game
pass
i don't think sony expected them to to
reach out mob yo what's that contract
say
oh it doesn't say nothing about gamepad
how about i give you this money and you
put that on gamepad since you were the
publisher
i don't think sony expected that and i
think from here going out
i think they're going to start putting
that in their marketing deals they're
going to start putting that in deals
they make with timed exclusives
because it's not the norm it's different
it's an easy loophole and i think
they're going to fix that uh we got
another five dollar super chat from uh
carla golis definitely butchered that
removing past it like i said
i feel like the last of us doesn't need
a re mask uh or remaster
it's not even that old remaster uh metal
gear solid or the twisted metal scythe
siphon filter i don't know remake than
uh that need a remake
so i agree with you i think that there's
a lot of games what's that um
that game with the dragoon legend of
dragon legendary people
people would go crazy that got remade
yeah
but at the end of the day it seems like
jim ryan's in that
i can make that for you uh colisa gloss
i definitely put your name again
but am i going to make any money from
that probably not yeah
yeah so that's where that's the worst
type of mindset if you're going by this
mindset well i'm just making this
because
it sells well that's when you just
become dependent on
that said game because like i just said
it sells right
so and that's what that was what
microsoft's biggest problem was they
stuck with halo gears and forza because
halo gears and forts are sold
out of their new games they were trying
to you know push my biggest issue
with sony is if they go this direction
yeah they're not gonna they're not gonna
nurture studios anymore
because the only people they're giving
the opportunity like that too
is the studio's already in orchard
yeah so but you know we'll have to see
we'll have to see what happens i'm
pretty sure you know once this e3
equivalent whatever they're doing
comes out of their conference then
you know what we'll be looking at the
new games we want to remember this stuff
but
all it takes it's a domino effect what
they're doing now is going to affect
what they do in two years
yeah uh right now you're not even seeing
what jim ryan is really doing
here probably a year year and a half to
two that's what you're gonna see what
jim ryan's doing
they're not even transparent without
that's just really killing them too
they're not transparent with
nobody when it comes to questions about
what's what's going on too it's like bro
people want answers give them the
answers
and plus things they invest
thousands upon thousands of dollars into
these brands people just want to know
what's going on
but wow yeah seventy dollars two like
three four games bro you spinning damn
near the equivalent of a console
if you bought four games or seven you
know i mean 70 dollars so it's like bro
it's
not it's it's so it's a question to you
do you have this headset i have that
headset
actually did not i got the sennheiser um
game once
all right so so you could go ahead and
take off if you want because i'm about
to uh
break down this headset real quick but
you can stay if you want it don't really
matter
all right so the audio on this headset
is good like
it's got like a knob thing that you
twist up and down to like turn
stuff up in the game volume like um hold
up
let me get it i got a
uh
here's the rigs the rigs eight hundreds
he tried to show me that the rigs they
have the same thing
i actually prefer this because this is a
little bit more up front
and forward like the top one's volume
the bottom one's game chat
now i mean this is this is fine but i
feel like it could be a little too much
like um i i still to this day i don't
know which one's which i think this is
the volume i don't know
but it's i i like it i like how i was
very worried how how it would feel you
know what i'm saying
it feels fine especially since i worked
up organs and stuff like it
doesn't like really mess with my ears
too much now here's the big thing
i'ma switch the volume i mean the mic
i'm gonna go
from this this yeti right here this this
marvelous audio
which is not the greatest audio but it's
definitely
the standards you can have for like a
podcast
now i'm going to switch to it right now
i'm going to go to this headset
tell me the difference okay
all right i i've switched on the stream
now let me switch in discord
and you could tell me if you if you feel
like
obviously you're going to get some form
of difference but tell me how
different it is all right here it is
here do you do you hear a huge
difference
uh it does sound like a boost in base
for sure do you guys hear a difference
a little different yeah like sean
farrell
hold up i i put the wrong one
keep talking blake um bit yeah yeah
so i gotta find out which one of these
controls your voice
oh yeah see i i should have
messed around a little bit more but can
you
can you guys tell the difference in the
audio that's that's
the curious thing i have for you right
now now let me find out why i can't hear
him oh all right can you hear me
all right there there can you hear me
all right can you tell a difference in
the audio
all right so i gotta talk a little
louder that's pretty much all
hello question testing one two three
testing
yes so i mean that's the only real issue
i have with this headset
is this mic's not the greatest quality
like
for but but it's a hundred dollars like
the uh this
this is a hundred and fifty
so i could totally understand where the
mic quality is yeah i know where i know
where it is
i just didn't know which ones which once
was audio which one's game volume
but i do i do like it for what it is
now obviously the good thing about xbox
right now is you can like you're not on
discord you can manually turn people up
and down
you could do that in xbox now so
the good thing about it is people can
barely
they can hear you but it's it's down a
little bit so now what
well no i i got this for pretty much
testing purposes
and the only thing i really need it for
is like the podcast to hear from because
i got this
this mic i don't really need the mic
portion of it
and it's like i said all people got to
really do is just turn me up and i sound
fine
but it is a little low if you're in an
xbox live party and
all they have to do is turn you up and
when they turn you up you sound fine but
it is low that's the only real issue i
got with this headset is i feel like
it's low
even with my toboggan off which i'm not
going to take it off but
even with it off the the headset fits on
my ears fine like it's not like over my
ears
but it is a little bit like cramped in
the
in it but it's not horrible if for for
the hundred dollars it's a very quality
headset
you know the good thing about this is
like if i'm playing
on um if i'm playing on my xbox
i can sync these up to my pc and listen
like a podcast or something at the same
time
so i like that they give you those type
of options
all right talk now everything i guess
yeah i switched things up all right so
that's pretty much all about the headset
like i said the headset's good it's it's
made
pretty good quality material it does
feel comfortable
uh the the the odd
the mic itself i feel like should have
been upgraded a little bit but
for a hundred dollars i don't think you
can go wrong with it but i do think
there might be better headsets for a
little bit more money
but uh anything uh where can people find
you a big cloud cause i gotta go to work
i gotta
i gotta go oh yeah no man oh yeah they
sure uh they should have me on uh this
is uh you know big cloud gaming
uh yeah you can find me youtube twitch
twitter gaming
and uh i'm about to be live at 5
30. we got a lot of talk about we're
doing she's jumping through but uh we
about to we got to talk a lot about
what's going on playstation so we're
going to be live definitely
definitely go check kids out because uh
who's going to be on that stream with
you
oh we got blaze we got um yeah we got
blaze we got
we got our next place it is worth it
enough go in there and listen to that
blaze man so we got uh two special
guests
so all right